aujourd'hui j'aimerais vous parler de
l'échelle hobbit scouts soldats qui unit
dès demain mais qui font mine en fait
des idées john brennan et de l'ua
ghallef notamment où l'idée c'est qu'il
ya un peu trois phases 3 état
psychologique dans lequel on est lorsque
l'on débat on peut être en mode hobbit
c'est à dire que bon en fait on s'en
fout un petit peu du coup on va pas
beaucoup participé on va aussi surtout
ne pas être beaucoup attentif suite il
ya le côté scouts scout c'est à dire qu
on est intéressé qu on est intrigué
qu'on cherche à comprendre et on est
calme aussi on est bienveillant et on
veut vraiment comprendre
et enfin il ya le côté soldats oula ça
correspond à wigan tribal tout ça où
l'idée c'est que on est en mode de furax
et qu'on veut défendre notre position au
jeune allemand qui en fait la position
de notre camp qui est un peu sacralisé
par les nôtres et c'est pour ça qu'on
veut le défendre et donc comme vous
l'aurez deviné en tout cas selon edf la
position idéale ou être sur cette
échelle c'est au niveau de scouts
l'idéal c'est d'être dans cette position
où on est vraiment intrigué par le
programme et on cherche vraiment à
comprendre ce qui se passe on cherche à
s'améliorer on cherche à bien faire ou à
mieux faire en tout cas et on a remporté
là on va chercher l'information va
s'informer
donc ça c'est vraiment l'état idéal et
malheureusement cet état est extrêmement
difficile à atteindre
malheureusement bien souvent on est soit
plutôt du côté
hobbit dire que sur des sujets juste pas
d'avis et en général c'est pas grave
c'est pas mal du tout de son futur petit
peu space qu'on a pas d'avis et consorts
font un petit peu et c'est pas si grave
en juin l'un d'eux s'en fout un petit
peu voilà si vous n'avez pas d'avis sur
quand est-ce que l'hypothèse de riemann
sera démontrée je voudrais passer c'est
pas grave
même moi je suis pas sûr que ce soit la
question qui nous intéresse le plus
malheureusement il ya des questions sur
lesquelles c'est beaucoup plus important
de ne pas être hobbit notamment des
problèmes qui sont un peu globaux et sur
lesquelles il ya besoin d'une réflexion
collective et surtout su du coup si on
est un hobbit mais avec beaucoup de
pouvoir ou de faculté quand on a un
mobile puissant
bah ça c'est un peu dommage c'est
vraiment limite un problème que de ne
pas prêter attention à des sujets qui
sont importants du coup souvent quand on
est un petit peu scouts ou hooligan on a
envie un peu de bouger un petit peu
c'est éviter de réveiller de
les sensibiliser et attirer leur
attention sur telle ou telle pièce
s'appelle changement climatique les
problèmes de justice sociale ou encore
le problème des ia et du fait qu'elle
maximise la rétention et que ça plein de
conséquences néfastes
ben ça y est les sujets qui sont le
vraiment vraiment important et sur
lequel semble problématique et d'être
trop hobbit en tout cas et du coup pour
réveiller les hobbits ballet ce côté les
hooligans sont là souvent essayer de
titiller de les agités et souvent les
oligan vont plutôt avoir une stratégie
coup de poing et c'est de m'être tapé du
poing sur la table de faire un clash un
cheat storm ou des choses dans le genre
et le problème c'est que souvent ce
genre de technique qui est qui très
efficace pour réveiller les hobbits et
pour pour les agités pour les mettre les
mettre dans des conditions où ils vont
prêter attention à une cause importante
malheureusement quand on fait ça ensuite
une conséquence potentielle d'avoir des
messages trop agressif c'est que les
hobbits deviennent tout à coup des
hooligans directement et ne passe pas
par la phase scouts et ça d'ailleurs
c'est aussi vrai des hooligans qui ont
beaucoup du mal à redescendre à la phase
de scouts parce que lorsqu'on est énervé
en énerver et souvent plus on cherche à
rationaliser notre énervement notre
entre colère en disant qu'elle est
légitime en trois ans des raisons pour
laquelle la colère est légitime et voilà
c'est un petit peu dommage et vous
renvoie vers notamment celles cette
vidéo où j'explique pourquoi on est
souvent en klaus et deux vidéos cette
autre vidéo ici et finalement ce n'est
pas forcément si utile d'être en colère
ça peut être utile de montrer de la
colère ne savait pas forcément utile
d'être soi même en colère ça peut être
utile un petit peu je peux me motiver
mais c'est pas si utile et surtout
lorsqu'on collard c'est très difficile
ensuite de redescendre à échelle de
scouts et on a tendance à ce juste
laissé emporter et c'est un poème du
coup vraiment difficile moi ce que
j'aimerais c'est qu'on soit beaucoup
plus à être en mode scout pour plus à se
poser des questions à bien réfléchir à
peser les pour et les contres a bien
nuancer les propos et à réfléchir aux
problèmes difficiles qui sont souvent
sont compliquées donc demande beaucoup
de réflexion tant qu'il faut vraiment
être inscrits pour tous ces problèmes
tous les problèmes que j'ai cité le
changement climatique le lait jus la
justice sociale où le problème de rugby
est bénéfique ce sont des problèmes va
vraiment vraiment complexe et améliorer
la situation sur tous ces prêts mais
vraiment une question difficile
et du coup mis les ultra important de ne
pas être en mode hooligans en tout cas
pas constamment de temps en temps en
redevenir un peu scout pour essayer de
vraiment réfléchir à ce qui peut être
fait je pense que c'est vraiment
important que l'on soit beaucoup plus en
mode écoute et surtout qu'on encourage
de plus en plus les gens à être en de
scouts
donc j'ai cru comprendre que je la
galette et bientôt sortir un livre qui
parle vraiment de ça justement et c'est
possible de battre moscou temps c'est
pas comme le vainqueur
le jazzman inatteignable être scout
c'est vraiment vraiment possible
il me semble que vraiment on est serait
souvent scouts sûr beaucoup beaucoup de
questions ce qui est dommage c'est que
sur les questions importantes parce que
c'est important on a tendance à être
tiraillé dans tous les sens et du coup a
basculé 3 pidement du côté hooligans est
typiquement sur des sujets qui ont à
voir avec la politique comme dessein
brennan le dit ce politique nous rend
stupide et méchant et du coup on a
tendance à être directement en mode
wigan huambo dos au but mais souvent pas
mal homogène et s'est du coup dommage
parce qu'on zappe cette partie scouts
qui est finalement là où on aimerait que
les gens soient et en particulier si on
a déjà éveillé jean-sylvain diamil et
les gens en mode hooligans il sent que
ça sert à rien de continuer de
persévérer dans le clash parce que ça va
perdre à persévérer dans l'état de ligue
à nice mme et à ce moment là c'est super
important surtout une fois qu'on a dit à
l'attention des gens ça sente super
important de calmer le débat d'être
beaucoup plus en méfiants pour pouvoir
amener tout le monde a basculé en notre
scout
je pense que c'est une échelle utiles à
prendre essayer de réfléchir à chaque
fois que vous êtes dans un débat où est
ce que vous vous placez dans cette
échelle et est ce que c'est un problème
que vous soyez là où vous êtes est
également là où sont les autres
sur cette échelle je pense que c'est une
partie très importante de débats parfois
compense débat on pense arguments mais
une partie importante au débat il me
semble c'est de prêter attention à ce
qu'on est
sur cette échelle allez un petit 360
pour finir avec le joli lac léman ue